der iran macht ernst gut ein jahr
nachdem donald trump aus dem atom
abkommen ausgestiegen ist vermeldet das
land das ist nun seine urananreicherung
wieder hochfahren werde
damit ist eine weitere eskalationsstufe
im usa iran konflikt erreicht und die
europäer schauen machtlos vom
spielfeldrand und das nur wenige tage
nach dem angriff auf zwei öl tanker im
golf von oman für den die usa und
großbritannien den iran verantwortlich
machen die region und die welt sitzen
auf einem pulverfass am persischen golf
das jeden moment explodieren kann
wie gefährlich die situation für die
region und den weltfrieden ist möchte
ich mit meinen gästen diskutieren und
begrüße sie sehr herzlich bei unter den
linden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und hier am tisch begrüße ich sehr
herzlich jürgen hardt den
außenpolitischen sprecher der cdu csu
fraktion im deutschen bundestag und
michael lüders politikwissenschaftler
islamwissenschaftler und präsident der
deutsch arabischen gesellschaft herzlich
willkommen man sie beide parat es ist
zwar erst sechs tage her aber es scheint
fast wie aus einer anderen zeit da haben
sie im focus gesagt dass sie davon
ausgehen dass donald trump eigentlich
verhandeln will und keinen krieg
wirklich provozieren möchte würden sie
das heute noch genauso sehen und sagen
ich bleibe bei meiner einschätzung das
ist zwar immer ein enormes risiko damit
verbunden wenn militärkräfte euro pro
konzentriert werden aber trump selbst
ist ja eigentlich angetreten um die
roller militärische rolle amerikas in
der welt zurück zu fahren er hat in
afghanistan seine position gegenüber den
wahlkampf geändert er hat für syrien den
abzug angekündigt allerdings noch nicht
realisiert aber jetzt eine neue
baustelle auf zu machen das wäre sein
wlan schlecht vermittelbar und die frage
des militärischen kriegsziels das
dahinter steht und wie man aus der sache
auch wieder rauskommt die steht in den
sternen also ich glaube das nicht
bevor wir da wirklich zu den details
kommen aber so was glauben sie hat diese
angriff verändert inwiefern hat die lage
sich verändert sind wir einen möglichen
krieg näher gekommen
wenn man sich überlegt mit was der iran
reagieren könnte auf die aus seiner
sicht wachsende bedrohung von außen
dadurch dass eben jetzt die sanktionen
seitens amerikas wieder eingeführt sind
das abkommen seitens amerikas auf eis
gelegt ist und die europäer können das
auch nicht ausfüllen könnte man
natürlich schon auf die idee kommen dass
der iran interesse daran hat die
versorgung der westlichen welt mit öl
aus dem persischen golf zu behindern und
zu schädigen
vielleicht auch die frischwasser
erzeugung der vereinigten arabischen
emirate die ja komplett aus dem
persischen golf kommt ich bin etwas in
sorge dass das tatsächlich
möglicherweise teil der strategie des
iran sein könnte da die region unsicher
zu halten und damit die logistik für
energie versorgung für
die übrige welt zu behindern aber ich
glaube die beweislage ist im augenblick
noch so dass wir da nur indizien für den
film haben auf die kleinen details
können wir gleich noch herr lüders seit
donnerstag im mai 2018 das abkommen
ausgesetzt hat abgesagt hatte eigentlich
den ganzen jahr ausgestiegen ist haben
viele schon von einer eskalation des
konflikts gesprochen war da schon der
einstieg zu einer situation wo wir sagen
das ganzen krieg führen
die situation hat in der tat eskaliert
begann zu eskalieren mit der einseitigen
aufkündigung des automarkts mit dem iran
am 8 mai des vorigen jahres durch die
usa obwohl übrigen signal staaten
russland china großbritannien frankreich
deutschland an diesem atom abkommen
festhalten wollten
es ist wichtig darauf hinzuweisen dass
laut der internationalen
atomenergiebehörde in wien die zuständig
ist für die überwachung dieses atom
abkommens es keine verstöße gegeben hat
ist hat nichts an meldungen gegeben dass
der iran sich an dieses abkommen nicht
halten würde gleichwohl ist das abkommen
aufgekündigt worden mit der offiziellen
begründung schwamms der iran habe gegen
den geist des abkommens verstoßen
was immer das heißt gemeint waren die
aktivitäten des irans in der region die
man auch in der tat kritisieren kann
aber das ist nicht gegenstand des atom
abkommens gewesen es gibt eine hardware
fraktion in den usa die die
konfrontation sucht mit dem iran
weil der iran das letzte verbliebene
land ist im weiten raum zwischen marokko
und indonesien kann man sagen was eine
antiamerikanische nicht prowestliche
linie fährt das zudem eng verbunden ist
mit dem syrischen machthaber baschar al
assad und vor allem mit russland und das
ist aus amerikanischer sicht nicht
akzeptabel kann man dann so weit gehen
dass man sagt es gibt ja auch kräfte die
den krieg wollen auf jeden fall gibt es
kräfte die diesen krieg wollen es ist ja
nicht so dass die situation jetzt erst
entstanden ist oder mit der aufkündigung
des automarktes wir können seit den
frühen 1919 jahren beobachten dass
konservative kräfte in neo konservative
kräfte den usa aber auch pro-israelische
pro saudische und premier an tische
lobbygruppen sukzessive auf nachfolgende
amerikanische regierungen eingewirkt
haben die konfrontation mit dem iran zu
verstärken um hier ein regimewechsel
herbeizuführen in der region selber
fühlen sich israel saudi arabien die
vereinigten arabischen emirate
insbesondere von dem iran bedroht und
insofern haben diese kräfte auf
konfrontation gesetzt es gibt aber
natürlich auch mäßigen der kräfte
innerhalb der us-administration auch
jetzt unter trump das sind nicht die
herren bolton der nationale
sicherheitsberater und der außenminister
mio das sind die hardliner
aber es gibt natürlich das pentagon das
verteidigungsministerium und auch die
wirtschaftlichen führer sind sehr in
sorge weil sie natürlich wissen dass ein
krieg gegen den iran von dem leute wie
bolton glauben dass das eine sache von
zwei drei wochen und dann würde niemals
kapitulieren
genau das wird nicht passieren es wird
dann wirklich zu einer sehr gefährlichen
eskalation kommen
herr hat schauen wir mal will ich
detaillierter auf das was da in der
letzten woche passiert ist der angriff
auf die beiden öltanker da haben
großbritannien und die usa gleich den
iran als den schuldigen ausgemacht ist
die schuldfrage denn wirklich geklärt
ich glaube der richtige ort diese frage
zu analysieren und zu besprechen ist der
un-sicherheitsrat weil wir schon sicher
sein müssen wenn wir vorwürfe an die
adresse der anrichten ich habe
allerdings natürlich im blick auf den
iran auch eine ganze reihe von anderen
beschwerden wir haben dieses anti atom
abkommen mit dem iran geschlossen als
deutschland mit unterschrieben
völlig richtig wie sie das dargestellt
haben das ist konkret um die atomare
bewaffnung also die iranische atombombe
ging um nichts anderes
aber es gibt das raketenprogramm des
iran es gibt terrorismus unterstützung
in vielen anderen ländern der region
jemen libanon und gaza streifen und
sofort nicht zuletzt natürlich in syrien
und es gibt diese anti-israelischer
rhetorik da werden raketen tests gemacht
dafür drauf geschrieben
diese rakete ist für israel bestimmt
also eine offenere provokation ist ja
kaum möglich und wir hatten eigentlich
gehofft dass über dieses abkommen und
über die die erfüllung des abkommens von
beiden seiten auch ein neuer
gesprächsfaden öffnet wird um über die
anderen
dinge und bekenntnisse zu reden so nach
dem motto und spatz es besser als die
taube auf dem dach der amerikanische
präsident sagt wenn man den iran nur
weiter mit sanktionen unter druck setzt
wird er zu einem besseren zu einem beta
deal bereit sein diese karte versuchte
auszuspielen letztlich könnten natürlich
1015 irrt man etwas hinbekommen
vielleicht verlängerung der laufzeit
oder so wo der amerikanische präsident
sagen kann das ist jetzt mein erfolg das
abkommen ist jetzt besser als es vorher
war
aber das war es in der letzten woche
passiert ist zeigt dass der iran wohl
auch nicht mehr an eine auflösung dieses
vertrags konfliktes glaubt sondern jetzt
will er freilich noch mal nach nach der
schuldfrage also herr wieder sagte ja
eben dass es durchaus auch mäßigende
kräfte in den usa gibt nichtsdestotrotz
den usa gleich gesagt das war der iran
das kann ich nicht beurteilen warum die
amerikanische politik oder eine mehrheit
der amerikanischen politik das teilt ich
weiß nur dass im blick auf das atom
abkommen das ja barack obama bzw der
damalige us-außenminister maßgeblich mit
vorangetrieben hat es im kongress in
beiden parteien also demokraten wie
republikaner erhebliche vorbehalte gab
es unter dem motto das reicht nicht die
israelische regierung netanyahu war
eigentlich immer gegen dieses abkommen
hinter den kulissen hört man in israel
auch andere stimmen so nach dem motto
besser das als nichts aber die
begeisterung war immer eingeschränkt und
trump hat die wahl auch gewonnen vor
zwei jahren weil er gesagt hat ich
steige aus diesen schlechten deal aus
der übrigen in amerika auch noch nicht
vom parlament ratifiziert
also er war noch nicht ist es kein
völkerrechts bruch seitens trumps jetzt
diesen vertrag aufzukündigen
aber es ist meines erachtens ein
falscher politischer schritt handy das
schauen wir noch mal auf dass das
ereignis mit denen mit den öltank
inwiefern würden sie sagen ist das was
die usa hervor gebracht hat
an beweisen kann ja nicht sagen oder
doch sagen inwiefern ist das wirklich
überzeugend sind es beweise die die usa
gegen den iran
die usa haben bislang keine beweise
vorgelegt es gibt behauptungen die
aufgestellt werden und ich glaube man
muss auch sehr vorsichtig sein dass
außenstehende jetzt irgendwie einer
seite die schuld zuzuweisen es ist
durchaus vorstellbar dass
revolutionsgardisten versucht haben den
druck zu erhöhen im kessel um die
amerikaner auf diese art und weise unter
druck zu setzen es ist aber genauso gut
denkbar dass die geheimdienste aus saudi
arabien aus den vereinigten arabischen
emiraten oder aus anderen ländern auf
die idee gekommen sind als provokateure
doch noch mal dafür sorge zu tragen dass
sich die spannungen weiter erhöhen
denn wenn es kräfte gibt in washington
die den krieg wollen gegen den iran
der muss man den ja irgendwie
legitimieren und das kann man nur indem
man eine behauptung aufstellt jetzt
kriegsgrund herhalten könnte wobei man
sich dabei teilweise sehr fremd ich
finde es sehr schön wenn ich aus den usa
höhere oder von britischem außenminister
jeremy hunt der denn er sagt na ja wir
wissen zwar nicht genau wer es war aber
es gibt eigentlich niemanden anderen bei
dem man sich vorstellen könnte dass er
es gewesen sein könnte also sagen
doppelter konjunktiv auf der grundlage
würde kein richter in deutschland
irgendeinen zivilen prozess führen
können auf der grundlage solcher wagen
behauptungen die gefahr die ich sehe ist
das hier ein druck aufgebaut wird wir
haben ja schon vor vier wochen etwa oder
für fünf wochen vier weitere tanker
gehabt die angegriffen worden sind hat
sich meyer richtig und auch da ist die
urheberschaft nicht ganz klar erklärt
worden oder man kann es vielleicht doch
nicht herstellen ich weiß aber noch gut
kann mich noch erinnern wie der john
bolton der nationale sicherheitsberater
in abu dhabi der hauptstadt der
arabischen emirate war vor allem monaten
dort erklärte es gebe eindeutige weise
das ist der iran war die allerdings bis
heute nicht vorgelegt hat also kurzum
wenn man sich auch daran erinnert dass
die amerikaner auch das in der
vergangenheit durchaus ihrer fantasie
freien lauf gelassen haben wenn es darum
den vergleich nachzogen zu begründen
dann muss man hier glaube ich sehr sehr
vorsichtig sein
herr hat wenn wir uns den iran mal
anschauen wer ist denn vorstellbar dass
es dort vielleicht auch kräfte gibt
die gegen die regierung oder gar nicht
mit wissen der regierung gehandelt hat
oder vielleicht sogar mit duldung der
regierung gehandelt sein dass vor
einiger zeit der iranische botschafter
dem ich vorgehalten habe diese
raketentests wo dieser aufschrift in
hebräischer schrift drauf war
ich habe es jetzt nicht den kopf aber
diese rakete ist für israel bestimmt
oder so dass er mir gesagt hat das sei
nicht die iranische regierung gewesen
sondern in der revolutionsgarden also
diese diese hat dieser wächterrat und
seine militärische eskorte ist im iran
wohl tatsächlich ein stück staat im
staate das letzte wort hat eben nicht
die regierung nicht die personen mit
denen wir öffentlich zu tun haben also
auch wenn der außenminister in der
region ist sondern das sind halt die
militärs die letztlich nur auf das
kommando der der geistlichen führer
hören und sie haben die haben ja auch
ihrerseits wiederum lange gegen dieses
abkommen opposition betreten ich kann
mich erinnern dass also erst im letzten
augenblick die geistlichen führer im
iran gesagt haben das sei ein gutes
abkommen nämlich in dem augenblick wo
klar war dass die regierung mit
unterstützung der bevölkerung das war
eine populäre maßnahme die leute haben
ja gehofft dass durch die
wirtschaftlichen lockerungen der
wohlstand im land vorankommt das war die
erwartung die die regierung erfüllen
wollte und die die wächter der die
mullahs sind erst im letzten augenblick
sozusagen dieser politik beigetreten
weil sie vermutlich befürchtet haben
dass mit einem solchen abkommen
natürlich auch eine eröffnung des landes
eine unweigerliche kontaktaufnahme von
vielen jungen menschen im land
vielleicht entsteht die dann die
ausstellung wird das regime untergräbt
stabilisieren können also es gibt wohl
22 macht pole in diesem land und es kann
natürlich sein dass es auch da einen
konflikt gibt
würden sie auch sagen dass es dort in
den revolutionsgarden kräfte gibt die
vielleicht gar nicht mehr kontrollierbar
sind
das iranische politische system ist sehr
komplex für außenstehende schwer zu
durchschauen weil das iranische system
ist halb in anführungsstrichen
demokratisch und halb inoffiziell es
gibt ja im iranischen parlament keine
parteien wie bei uns sondern es gibt
verschiedene seilschaften und
machtzentren die in einem komplizierten
checks and balances versuchen
kompromisse zu finden in den großen
fragen die das land betreffen die
revolutionsgardisten sind in der tat ein
staat im staate aber es ist und
ungeachtet ihrer mentalität die nicht
immer serafin das mit blick auf den
westen durch ausgewählt und geneigt
dieses atom abkommen uneingeschränkt
mitzutragen das problem ist nur dass
sich viele im iran nicht nur
revolutionsgardisten fragen was haben
uns eigentlich 13 jahre der
verhandlungen mit dem westen gebracht
wir haben auf die atomare bewaffnung
verzichtet im gegensatz zu nordkorea
nordkorea hat jetzt die atombombe keiner
kennt denkt darüber nach nordkorea
anzubauen anzugreifen und nun haben also
die iraner diesen vertrag unterzeichnet
müssen feststellen dass verträge diese
mit den usa unterschreiben
im zweifel das papier nicht wert sind
auf dem sie geschrieben stehen das
fördert natürlich nicht gerade das
vertrauen in westliche politik die
hoffnung war zunächst da dass die
westlichen europa großbritannien
frankreich deutschland doch hier ein
teil des wirtschaftlichen schadens
ausgleichen könnten der durch die
wirtschaftssanktionen die usa können sie
einen entstandene worden ist und das
können die europäer nicht das wollen sie
vor allem auch nicht ursprünglich war ja
die idee dieser institution die
geschaffen worden ist mit sitz in paris
ins text genannt dass die europäer ihre
gesamten handelsbeziehung im idealfall
über ins text abwickeln könnten mit dem
iran so dass die sanktionsdrohungen die
usa in gewisser weise für die europäer
ins leere laufen es gab dann aber so
viel druck der usa auf die europäer das
in sächsisch ein bisschen gewandelt hat
man will jetzt nur noch humanitäre
leistungen abwickeln über den stacks das
betrifft die ist den handel mit
lebensmitteln und mit medizinischem
gerät das reicht den iranern natürlich
nicht sie sind sehr enttäuscht von den
europäern und perspektivisch wird es
wohl dazu führen dass sich der iran
verstärkt noch als bisher in richtung
russland china und indien wenden wird
vor einem jahr hat donald trump ja das
abkommen vor allen dingen deshalb für
abgesagt weil er sagt das wäre ein
schlechter deal und mit seinen
sanktionen ja eigentlich ein besseren
deal erreichen wollte hat er denn da
irgendetwas erreicht oder geht es in die
richtige richtung das ist meines
erachtens die fehleinschätzung und
wendig in washington mit kollegen auf
dem will rede also aus dem
amerikanischen parlament gibt es dort
eben auch viele die das so sehen
die erwartung dass man seitens der soll
ich jetzt mal westlichen welt den iran
zu einer art politischen kapitulation
gegenüber dem
amerika und den anderen zwingen könnte
so nach dem motto sind dann bereit einen
vertrag zu unterschreiben der deutlich
weiter geht als das jetzige abkommen das
ist meine sachen sind hoch schluss weil
ich mir nicht vorstellen kann dass
russland und china hat das zulassen
würden also russland und china stehen
zwar auf der seite derer die gemeinsam
mit dem un sicherheitsrat dieses anti
atom bombe abkommen gemacht hätten china
und russland stünden sicherlich auf der
seite der anderen sicherheitsrats
nationen wenn es um die frage gegen das
vertragswerk zu bearbeiten zu agenten
ergänzen und zu erweitern
aber wenn das substanziell quasi zu
einem eine offenbarung des iran
gegenüber amerika kommen würde würde
russland china wahrscheinlich
dazwischengehen und im zweifel auch dann
im bus unterlaufen und deswegen glaube
ich dass diese strategie des
amerikanischen präsidenten
wenn sie eine aussicht auf erfolg gehabt
hätte hätte man ja sagen können okay das
ist vielleicht ein bisschen beton ja
also risiko aber es hat immerhin die
perspektive etwas besseres machen ich
glaube das war von anfang an zum
scheitern verurteilt und der ein oder
andere in washington sieht das genauso
und ich fürchte die letzten monate haben
gezeigt dass letztlich doch die
situation so ist wie ich sie gerade
beschrieben haben
da würde ich direkt nochmal nachfragen
wollen ist es nicht vielleicht sogar so
dass dass die hardliner im iran sogar
noch gestärkt hat letztendlich die
subvention die idee der amerikaner war
ja dass im zuge der
wirtschaftssanktionen die iranische
bevölkerung frustriert über eigene
regierung sich erheben würde gegen das
eigene regime das zu denken muss man
gelinde gesagt sehr naiv sein eine
ähnliche logik haben die amerikaner und
die mit ihnen verbündeten briten
verfolgt im irak zur zeit von saddam
hussein nachdem der kuwait besetzt hatte
man hat das land über jahre hinweg mit
wirklich brutalen sanktionen überzogen
am ende waren über eine million iraker
gestorben als ergebnis medizinischer
versorgung also wirklich eine furchtbare
katastrophe trotzdem haben sie sich
nicht gegen saddam hussein erhoben
alleine deswegen nicht weil sie dafür
viel zu geschwächt waren
und die iraner das darf man nicht
unterschätzen die amerikaner agieren ja
vielfach wie wir das jetzt nicht
verallgemeinern es gibt natürlich auch
sehr kluge amerikanische strategen
selbstverständlich aber ich sag mal der
politischen mainstream bei den
demokraten bei den republikanern glaubt
immer dass die welt
allein so genommen wie man sie in
amerika sieht iran haben wir eine eigene
geschichte
wir haben eine eigene historische
erfahrung ist eine kulturnation 3000
jahre alt und die jüngere geschichte
jüngere erfahrung die die iraner gemacht
haben mit den usa waren alles andere als
positiv bei aller wertschätzung die die
meisten iraner für die usa und für die
amerikaner von hollywood bis hin zum
lebenswandel den usa haben aber
vergessen wir nicht dass sind ja auch
alles traumatische erfahrung für die
iraner
1953 sind die usa gemeinsam mit den
briten interveniert in ihrer im iran
haben den damals demokratisch gewählten
ministerpräsidenten mossa deck gestürzt
bei der sich erschreckt hatte zwei jahre
zuvor 51 die iranische und industrie zu
verstaatlichen
daraufhin kam die diktatur des schahs an
die macht der aber in der eigenen
bevölkerung wenig rückhalt hatte und nur
durch die aktive unterstützung mit hilfe
der geheimdienste von ausland
insbesondere usa und israel sich an der
macht halten konnte
das ergebnis war die iranische
revolution 1979 ohne diesen putsch 53
hat der evolution 79 gar nicht gegeben
wenn man es zu ende denkt dann muss man
sagen dass die probleme die wir heute
haben mit dem iran oder glauben zu haben
im wesentlichen probleme sind die die
spätfolge sind einer furchtbaren fehler
entscheidung die im jahr 1953 ihren
anfang genommen hatte so weit denkt
natürlich kein politiker und so weit
denken auch die wenigsten aber trotzdem
man muss dieses im hintergrund haben die
iraner sind durchaus traumatisiert was
amerikanische politik anbelangt sie
glauben dem westen nicht so ohne
weiteres
und sie wissen seitdem seit 1980 saddam
hussein iran überfallen hatte
die iraner hätten diesen krieg ja
geworden nach zwei jahren faktisch schon
aber die amerikaner dafür gesorgt dass
der irak den krieg noch lange
weiterführen konnte bis 1988
gleichzeitig haben die amerikaner waffen
verkauft auch an den iran
ich erwähne das deswegen weil es
hochinteressant ist dieser ihrem konto
aus skandalen der im kollektiven
bewusstsein viele iraner immer noch
lebendig ist wir reden heute davon dass
gamer in erbfeindschaft beispielsweise
zwischen iran und israel
das ist alles kokolores in den ganzen
80er jahren während des gesamten krieges
haben nie weniger als 100 israelische
militärexperten den iran beraten in
seiner kriegsführung gegen den irak es
gab immer enge beziehungen selbst noch
zur zeit von fromi es gab in den 1990 er
jahren den versuch des reformpräsidenten
khatami die beziehungen mit den usa und
zu israel zu normalisieren zu verbessern
die antwort der regierung bush dame
wir sind nicht interessiert es gibt also
eine geschichte vieler missverständnisse
und versäumnisse und bei aller
berechtigten kritik an der iranischen
führung muss man sich immer daran
erinnern dass die unter ganz schwierigen
bedingungen versuchen ihr land so über
die runden zu kriegen dass es eben nicht
zu einer weiteren kriegerischen
auseinandersetzung kommt sollte das
geschehen werden sich die iraner weil
sie mehrheitlich patrioten sind mit
sicherheit hinter ihre regierung stellen
führen natürlich die iraner führen an
vielen ecken der region krieg also sie
führen krieg in jedem sie führen krieg
in syrien sie führen krieg im
gazastreifen
sie führen auch die krieg gegen israel
mit der hisbollah im libanon und im
gaza-streifen also insofern ist die
aggressive attitüde des iran in der
region schon erheblich und ich glaube
die ursachen dafür liegen nicht nur in
der geschichte die sie jetzt gerade
beschrieben haben die könnte man
natürlich jetzt auch noch 100 jahre nach
vorne in die in die vergangenheit weiter
verlängern
ich glaube entscheidend ist dass der
konflikt zwischen den verschiedenen
religionsgruppen olle spielt ich glaube
es geht in der region tatsächlich auch
um die frage wer ist der wahre hüter des
islamischen glaubens wer hat eigentlich
die geistige führerschaft in der region
da haben wir die grundformation zwischen
arabischen halbinsel und den arabischen
staaten und wir haben eben die die china
die geführt wird von vom iran oder wo
iran sich als der geistige führerschaft
ansieht und ich glaube wenn dieser
konflikt nicht in irgendeiner weise
besänftigt beigelegt entschärft wird und
im augenblick wird der er verschafft
aber durch die akteure in der region
kriegen wir keinen frieden in der region
auch keine sicherheit für israel und das
ist letztlich das thema wo wir überlegen
müssen was können wir als europäer tun
handel und wandel des unsere antwort
gewesen
wie kriegen wir den iran besänftigen
blick auf die atomare bewaffnung das ist
auch unsere strategie gegenüber anderen
akteuren in der region aber
gegen bomben an tankschiffen und dass
sie da dran waren dass das ist ja
unbestritten die fahrgäste wie hat sie
angebracht sind natürlich diplomatische
gute worte wird da noch mal eine
richtige ja die seelenlage der
amerikaner aus ein bisschen beschrieben
haben und ja sagen dass sie da auch
viele gespräche führen in washington
wäre es denn überhaupt denkbar dass in
den usa ein krieg mit dem iran rückhalt
hätte denn jump ist ja eigentlich auch
angetreten zu sagen amerika fest und ich
zuerst die amerikaner aus dem ausland
überall ab wieder zurück ins inland wäre
es überhaupt denkbar dass da eine
stärkere eskalation auch in richtung
krieg mit rückhalt der amerikaner
stattfinden kann
zunächst einmal glaube ich nicht dass
donald trump wirklich davon überzeugt
ist dass militärische lösung also der
tatsächliche einsatz von streitkräften
nicht sie zu haben damit zu drohen die
innenräume zu stellen dass wir das etwas
anderes abschreckung funktioniert auch
aus seiner sicht aber dass konkrete
krieg führen
ich glaube ich da ist er sehr
realistisch und weiß immer dass das was
im generale und admirale im zweiten
vortragen dass man da von der ganze
riesige portion abziehen muss dass es ja
übrigens eine erfahrung aller
amerikanischen präsidenten dass das
militär sich manchmal selbst überschätzt
deswegen glaube ich wie gesagt nicht an
diese kriegsgefahr ich glaube dass in
amerika dann eine eine stimmung bis hin
zur möglichen eskalation aufgebe wenn es
tatsächlich gegen israel gingen also
wenn wir tatsächlich eine situation
kommen in der er das existenzrecht
israels durch einen krieg in der region
gefährdet wäre dann könnte ich mir
vorstellen gibt es in amerika auch in
der öffentlichen meinung eine mehrheit
gesagt dort amerika muss sich aktiv
einschalten andere szenarien bei denen
dass da eine breite öffentliche
unterstützung gibt was ja weil ja
vielleicht nicht ganz unwichtig dann ist
wenn nächstes jahr der der amerikanische
präsident gewählt wird
das sehe ich eigentlich nicht ich würde
gerne wenn ich darf er in einer
angelegenheit widersprechen und eine
andere konkretisieren sie haben zu recht
verwiesen auf die religiösen differenzen
die es gibt in der region saudi arabien
sieht sich als schutzmacht der sunniten
iran sieht sich als schutzmacht der der
schicke jetzt ist es aber trotzdem ein
irrtum zu glauben das ist ein religiöser
konflikt wäre die religion ist zwar eine
bruchlinie in der konfrontation zwischen
saudi arabien und dem iran aber es ist
nicht die ursache
das kann man alleine daran sehen dass
zur zeit des schahs die beziehung
zwischen saudi arabien und dem iran sehr
sehr eng waren die beziehungen wurden
erst sehr schlecht als es zu iranischen
revolution kam und natürlich die saudis
große angst hatten dass diese iranische
revolution übergreifen könnte auf das
eigene land und die saudis ihrerseits
eine revolution machen dieses regime
hinweggefegt wird von dem moment an
haben sich beziehungen zwischen saudi
arabien und dem iran massiv verschoben
aber dies ist ein politischer konflikt
einen konflikt wenn man will um die um
die es geht um die vorherrschaft in der
region
die religion ist die bruchlinie aber
nicht die ursache sie haben vor riesen
auf die auf die einmischung des irans in
der region in den verschiedenen ländern
in den syrien der männer und so weiter
das ist vollkommen richtig dieses zu
benennen
man sollte aber bei aller distanzierung
zu diesem regime doch klar benennen
warum dass die iraner tun das ist nicht
ausdruck eines expansionsstreben sum der
expansion will sondern die iraner haben
unmittelbar nach der revolution erfahren
dass sie angegriffen werden vom irak
nämlich der irrtümlicherweise sagt
glaubte der iran seine schwester er zum
beispiel sind sie hierzu den zeitungen
nicht angegriffen worden und die anti
israelische kampagne oder das ist der
englischen töne sind ja sehr laut von
seiten ist ja aber das ist doch alles
rhetorik das glaubt doch keiner
ich meine die iranische bevölkerung
sowieso nicht israelis glauben ist ja
nur ja aber auch da gibt es genügend
differenzierende stimmen weil man redet
mit vertretern des israelischen militärs
oder der politik dann wissen die auch
dass der iran keine wirkliche bedrohung
darstellt für israel
bei aller freundschaft die aufgebaut
wird von beiden seiten zueinander
alleine deswegen weil israel über
atombomben verfügt der iran nicht eine
existenzielle bedrohung israels ist
nicht gegeben
aber das liegt der entscheid gab es
ausschreitungen aber lasse ich mich mal
der daten lassen sich mal kurze gedanken
zu ende führen warum ist also der iran
sozusagen expandiert in die region man
hat sich verbunden mit allen möglichen
schiitischen organisation von
afghanistan bis zum libanon
warum macht der iran das der grund ist
vorwärtsverteidigung sie
wissen dass hier im kriegsfall mit den
usa und israel zwei sehr ernste
militärische gegner haben denen sie in
einem konventionellen krieg nicht gegen
diese in einem konventionellen krieg
nicht bestehen können sie müssen sich
also also militärisch verteidigen wenn
es zum krieg kommen sollte gegen den
iran
dann werden diese gesamten schiitischen
milizen von afghanistan bis lieber noch
ein bisschen fußballer in bewegung
gebracht gegen die usa gegen israel
gegen soll iran gegen die vereinigten
arabischen emirate das ist das kalkül
dahinter
das kritisiert man im westen kann man
auch völlig zu recht kritisieren eine
kluge politik würde darin bestehen eine
kluge politik würde darin bestehen dass
man mit dem iran nach dem atom abkommen
weiter verhandelt hätte der iran ist
bereit zu verhandeln aber er will
gegenleistung nicht angegriffen zu
werden und zwar glaubwürdige
gegenleistung und man kann nicht finde
ich glaubwürdig die iranische
intervention in der region kritisieren
ohne gleichzeitig zu benennen das dass
die türkei israel saudi arabien und die
usa sowieso in großem maßstab tun die
usa haben seit den terroranschlägen des
11 september 2001 in fünf islamischen
ländern kriege herbeigeführt muss noch
mal nachfragen also das muss ich noch
mit hilfe von terror sprechen dann ist
das ja keine verteidigung sondern ist
das auch ein angriff von seiten des iran
und das wird ja jetzt nicht nur also der
der angriff oder auch die bedrohung
gegenüber israel muss man ja auch immer
aus der anderen 16 israel fühlt sich
bedroht weil sie eben die raketen aus
dem gazastreifen
entsprechend spüren ja man muss aber
immer gucken mit wem man redet und ob
man jetzt sozusagen der veröffentlichten
meinung in bestimmten medien folgt in
israel oder ob man mit leuten sich
unterhält die sich wirklich auskennen
und die auch die gefechtslage kennt
jeder israelische general der sein
handwerk versteht und alle von dem
verstehen ihr handwerk weiß ganz genau
dass natürlich der iran eine
theoretische bedrohung darstellt aber
keine faktische wie gesagt der israel
verfügt über bis zu 400 atombomben der
der iran über keine dass sich die
israelis subjektiv bedroht fühlen durch
den iran kann ich durchaus
nachvollziehen aber es gibt auch viele
in der nachbarschaft ich soll jetzt die
sich durch israel bedroht fühlen
idealerweise würde man eine bessere welt
schaffen indem man sich zum beispiel
einsetzt für eine atomwaffenfreie
regionen des nahen und mittleren ostens
und es sind insbesondere die beiden
vorzeige demokratien auf der welt
schlechthin nämlich die usa und israel
die sich dieser überlegung vor
lawson haben in der vergangenheit und
umgegend und im gegenteil wir erleben
jetzt gerade das mit wissen und
billigung der israelis und in wissen und
belegung der amerikaner saudi arabien
kronprinz man mit sammer an dabei ist
nicht nur sein land nuklear zu
entwickeln friedlich was er kann sondern
es gibt auch ein atomprogramm ist es
ganz klar dass die saudis darauf
bestehen uran anzureichern ohne
kontrolle aus dem ausland und präsident
trump lässt sie gewähren weil man eben
atomkraftwerke fatal verkaufen will
in den in richtung saudi-arabien es ist
tatsächlich so wenn man einmal anfängt
sich mit diesen dingen zu befassen
wenn es nicht so wie es jeder zu den
opfern also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen
das was iranischer terrorismus gegen
israel und gegen zivilbevölkerung in der
region treibt ist mit vorne verteidigung
absolut nicht zu erklären abgesehen
davon dass diese militärischen theorie
der oder legitimität von vorne
verteidigung können sie für jede art von
von von intervention herhalten da können
sie auch die russische besetzung der
krim alles mit rechtfertigen das ist
original sowie putin reden würde
das lehne ich strikt ab eine solche
position und ich finde terrorismus sowie
er dort stattfindet ja also beschuss von
israel durch raketen was ja im wochen
oder monats rhythmus stattfindet die
situation im libanon wie wir sie haben
die sind über die schreckliche situation
in syrien wo putin assad und die iraner
gemeinsam fast bomben auf die
zivilbevölkerung abwerfen das finde ich
absolut unterirdisch und das hat auch
nichts zu tun mit irgend einen legitimen
selbstbehauptungs recht des iran
niemand würde den iran angreifen wenn er
seine unterstützung für den terrorismus
zurück ziehen würde und ich glaube dass
wir im jemen selbstverständlich eine
friedenslösung hinbekommen wenn der iran
nur bereit wäre seine militärische
unterstützung für die rookies
einzustellen und auch von dort fliegen
raketen auf saudi arabisches territorium
es hat ja raketen aus dem jemen auf
saudi arabisches gebiet gegeben bis nach
riad es hat diese auch ungeklärten wir
haben über die vier schiffe geredet
jetzt über die zwei schiffe letzte woche
ist hat auch ein oder zwei angriffe auf
pipelines systeme mit unbemannten
drohnen einigen geschichten gegeben wo
man nicht arbeiten her kommen also
jemand vermutlich aber eben die
technologie vermutlich
aus dem jemen das ist ein aggressives
verhalten und das in die schranken zu
weisen das war ja unser ziel mit diesem
chip und wir haben gesagt genau dass wir
eine atomare aufrüstung der region für
nicht verhindern dazu dient dieses
abkommen weil es zunächst einmal
verhindert dass der iran sich bewaffnet
und damit diese spirale wenn die iraner
die bombe haben dann wollen die anderen
sie auch haben dass diese spirale
gestoppt wird und deswegen ist das
schade dass dieses abkommen außer kraft
gesetzt worden ist selbst wenn es ein
unvollkommenes abkommen ist hätte es
doch die atomare bewaffnung des iran
meines erachtens verhindert sie haben
richtig gesagt die die überprüfung zeigt
dass der iran sich an die formalen
vorgaben des abkommens gehalten hat
bestreitet der amerikaner bringen auch
nicht die sagen ja es ist zudem gerade
diese versteuern
aber es ist explizit eben nicht über das
raketenprogramm gesprochen worden nicht
über terror unterstützung nicht über
israel politik dass der boden darüber zu
reden und voranzukommen in kleinen
schritten zu einem frieden in der region
der boden ist im augenblick leider sehr
steinig unser außenminister hat versucht
das 60 hoch es war von vornherein klar
dass diese mission in die region
vermutlich keinen sichtbaren
kurzfristigen erfolg zeitigen wird
deswegen finde ich es gut dass er auch
trotzdem seine reputation in die
waagschale geworfen hat und diesen
besuch gesagt hat ich würde mir wünschen
wenn wenn der geist dass letztlich die
diplomatie über die gewalt siegen muss
wenn der geist ein stück weit in der
region auch wieder fuß fasst
das wäre meine auffällig dass inwiefern
sind die sanktionen denn da ein probates
mittel war letztendlich dann ja die
finanzielle unterstützung auch für die
terror unterstützung fehlen also
zunächst einmal sind diese sanktionen
sowie die usa sie verhängt haben diese
sekundären sanktionen insbesondere von a
bis z völkerrechtswidrig es gibt
überhaupt gar kein rechtliches maßstab
kein rechtliches instrument dass ein
land a
alle anderen länder der welt ebenfalls
in die haftung nimmt auf das sie
ebenfalls keinen handel treiben mit dem
iran das ist rein rechtlich nicht
möglich das ist das privileg das man hat
als weltmacht dass man sozusagen
bedingungen diktieren kann die auch für
andere gültig sein sollen das problem
ist dass von diesen sanktionen in erster
linie die iranische bevölkerung
getroffen wird und zwar die iranische
mittelschicht
und das ist ausgerechnet diejenige
gesellschaftliche gruppierung die am
ehesten und eigentlich als einzige in
der lage wäre eine reform von innen
heraus aus dem iran heraus
herbeizuführen indem man nun diese
mittelschicht in die verarmung treibt
mit hilfe der inflation insbesondere die
jetzt entstanden ist im iran erreicht
man genau das gegenteil von dem was man
erreichen will
es ist eine radikalisierung blieben eine
verarmung der bevölkerung und erst recht
ein schulterschluss mit dem regime
gegeben aber ich habe auch kein geld
mehr für die unterstützung von
terrororganisationen ja aber wissen sie
ich muss ihnen gestehen ich finde diese
argumentation doch ein bisschen hole
dann müssen wir die begriffe klären ich
habe ihnen aufmerksam zugehört in ihrer
analyse der gegebenen verhältnisse in
der region und ich verstehe ihren
standpunkt ich halte ihnen dennoch für
zu kurz gegriffen
sie haben den jemen erwähnt das ist ein
thema für sich ich will den boden jetzt
nicht zu weit spannen aber ich finde man
kann nicht glaubwürdig das iranische
engagement im jemen kritisieren ohne
gleichzeitig zumindest der
vollständigkeit halber trevi dass saudi
arabien seit 2015 einen
völkerrechtswidrigen angriffskrieg führt
im jemen mit aktiver amerikanischer und
britischer unterstützung die in
gewaltigen umfang waffen darf ärgerlich
und gewaltigen umfang waffen dafür
liefern und mit diesen waffen wird
dieses land angegriffen es sind
amerikanische und britische
militärberater in riad und anderswo in
saudi arabien tätig die den saudis
erzählen welche ziele ins auge in im
jemen sie bombardieren können es sind
gewaltige zerstörungen die im jemen
angerichtet worden sind es hat mich
selber interessiert im zusammenhang mit
den recherchen zu meinem buch armageddon
im orient wie diese connection den den
iran es für sie und nimmt diese
eigenwerbung betrifft zu entschuldigen
aber ich habe in diesem zusammenhang
einmal recherchiert worin besteht
eigentlich der iranische einsatz im
jemen und ich habe mich mit
jemenitischen experten auf diesem gebiet
unterhalten die sich genau auskennen mit
den verhältnissen dort die jemenitische
die iranische unterstützung für die
sogenannten hutu rebellen im jemen
besteht darin dass die hisbollah und die
revolutionsgardisten jeweils etwa 40
militärberater noch einmal jeweils 40
militärberater im jemen unterhalt
die die hus hieß darin unterrichten wie
sie die überwiegend amerikanischen
raketen die sie verschießen in richtung
saudi-arabien zielgenau einnorden warum
machen sie das das hat wenig zu tun mit
dem iran oder nicht mit dem geraden
sondern die saudis zerstören dieses land
die hippies leisten die im widerstand
und iran haben erkannt sie können mit
sehr wenig aufwand nämlich mit 80
militärberatern es schaffen den saudis
ein problem herbeizuführen
das iranische die iranische
unterstützung für die houthi-rebellen so
sehr man die kritisieren mag ist
entschuldigung peanuts gemessen an den
massiven unterstützungen die das
saudische regime erfährt aus den
westlichen ländern bis hin zu einem
freibrief nach belieben dort das land zu
zerstören
gerade so aus der hohlen hand heraus
gesagt das wäre das völlig
völkerrechtswidrig es gibt an der linie
es gibt eine legitime jemenitische
regierung die von den hotels die vom
iran unterstützt werden angegriffen
werden und die dieses land in einen
bürgerkrieg hält diese legitime medici
regierung die vereinten nationen haben
dazu eine resolution gefasst hat
natürlich das recht um unterstützung zu
bitten und solange diese regierung die
von der völkergemeinschaft von den
vereinten nationen als legitim anerkannt
ist diesen wunsch an die saudis richtet
oder an die von der dauer des geführte
allianz auf unterstützung
dann ist das zunächst einmal in die
völkerrechtswidrig was an dem saudi
einsatz in jemen möglicherweise ein
verstoß gegen das völkerrecht bar ist
dass das möglicherweise die
verhältnismäßigkeit nicht gewahrt weil
die üblicherweise im letzten jahr rund
10.000 natürlich haben den letzten jahr
wir haben den letzten jahr und dem
vorletzten jahr bilder gehabt von
zerstörten zivilen einrichtungen in
diesem lande wo man sagt wenn man ein
krieg gegen aufständische führt darf man
eine solche eskalation des kampfes also
eine solche in mitleidenschaft ziehen
von zivilbevölkerung nicht in kauf
nehmen aber der einsatz ansicht der das
engagement an der seite der legitimen
jedem regierung ist nicht
völkerrechtswidrig und ich habe in den
interessanterweise seit der hafen in der
den logistik für die rebellen geflossen
ist seit dieser hafen nach dem abkommen
das vor einigen monaten getroffen worden
das abkommen seit dieser hafen
einigermaßen befriedet ist ist ja auch
die eskalation also die massivität der
kampfhandlungen zurückgegangen
die saudis und die vereinigten
arabischen emirate meines wissens machen
die feindlichen amerika habe ich
erwartet gegenwärtig überhaupt keine
militäraktion mehr im leben also wir
haben eine chance auf frieden für den
jemen größte humanitäre katastrophe die
wir im augenblick beobachten wir haben
eine echte chance und die chance besteht
darin dass sowohl saudi arabien als auch
den vereinigten arabischen emirate sagen
wir sind zu einer politischen
friedlichen lösung dieses konfliktes
bereit aber das setzt voraus dass der
iran seine und die unterstützung auf
lässt ich habe in saudi arabien in riad
und auch in abu dhabi also bei den
vereinigten arabischen emiraten gehört
beide sind einverstanden wenn es eine
inklusive regierung des landes gibt also
eine regierung die als
übergangsregierung nicht mehr nur aus
der negativen jemenitischen regierung
besteht sondern eben auch die muttis mit
einbezieht aber eben die wut ist die
jemeniten und nicht die iranisch die
sich aus sicht der der der saudis und
der vs hinter diesen tiefs verstecken
deswegen würde ich gerne noch mal
zurückkommen zum iran heute wurde
mitgeteilt dass man die urananreicherung
wieder wieder hochfährt das in diesem
monat wahrscheinlich die grenzwerte die
ursprünglich mal nehmen abkommen
vereinbart wurden überschreiten wird was
bedeutet das denn für das abkommen das
abkommen damit endgültig tot und vor
allem was bedeutet das für europa es war
für europa legitim an den eine lockerung
der wirtschaftssanktionen festzuhalten
solange für uns klar war dass der rat
sich an das abkommen hält
wenn der iran jetzt von sicheres
entscheidet das auch für ihn das
abkommen nicht mehr gilt sind wir
natürlich auf den punkt vor beginn der
verhandlungen letztlich zurückgeworfen
und die europäische union
idealerweise alle anderen auch müssen
entscheiden wie sie dann darauf
reagieren leider entfällt damit diese
geschäftsgrundlage die immer unsere
moralische argumentation war ja wir
haben immer gesagt das hat auch
außenminister maas gegenüber rani noch
mal vorgetragen
in dem augenblick wo ihr euch an das
abkommen haltet habt ihr den vorteil
dass wir zumindest heuer fürsprecher
sind im blick auf dieses abkommen und
zumindest die dinge
machen die wir machen können das problem
ist ja dass ein unternehmen das aus
europa heraus handel mit iran betreibt
damit leben muss dass die amerikaner
diesem unternehmen sagen du kannst
handel mit dem iran treiben aber dann
kannst du keinen handel mehr mit amerika
treiben und das europäische
internationale unternehmen das sich das
erlaubt das amerika-geschäft sozusagen
hinten runter fallen zu lassen
das gibt es leider nicht und deswegen
ist die situation so wie sie ist dass
die faktisch natürlich die amerikanische
kündigung auch dazu führt dass auch wir
nicht in dem maße mit dem iran da
unsererseits vertragstreu sein können
wie wir das gerne wäre ich hoffe dass
die nächsten tage genutzt werden
vielleicht doch noch was zu bewegen ich
glaube aussicht sich an regeln finden ja
ich sage nur der amerikanische präsident
selbst müssten ein interesse daran haben
in der außenpolitik endlich mal einen
erfolg einzufahren ja also er hat die
außenpolitik ja zusammen großen thema
gemacht dazu gehört die handelspolitik
also alles amerika und der rest der welt
und er hat ganz viele baustellen
eröffnet
nordkorea ist auch eine die handels
handelsstreit mit mit mit china ist eins
der die friedensfrage kuhstall plan ist
ein anderes und wenn er tatsächlich
einen erfolg vorweisen könnte dass es
ein besseres ccp also ein atom abkommen
gebe als das was obama verhandelt hat
und wenn es nur die verlängerung der
frist laufzeit von zehn jahren auf 25
jahre wäre oder irgendwie so etwas dann
hätte er formal einen grund zu sagen wir
steigen wieder ein und das hat sich
gelohnt dass ich diesen druck aufgebaut
die das werden ja unter der dusche steht
morgens und überlegt was kann ich denn
eigentlich vorweisen als erfolg meiner
außenpolitik wäre das ein eine low
hanging foto zu sein was er unter der
dusche denkt ist lasse ich mal
dahingestellt
die besten ideen oder durch aber ehrlich
dass da hatte ich doch gleich mal eine
in niefern glauben sie denn dass das
überhaupt ein szenario
aussicht auf erfolg hat also er ist es
nicht vielmehr immer wieder trumps ziel
nur bilaterale verhandlungen zu führen
und das multilaterale eigentlich völlig
aus dem vorteil dass multilaterale
interessiert präsidentschaft nicht im
geringsten die europäer nimmt ja auch
nicht ernst und die tragik ist dass die
europäer noch immer nicht begriffen
haben und wenn ich die europäer sage mal
nicht vor allem die europäische union
und die bundesregierung
sie haben noch immer nicht begriffen
dass diese regierung in washington nur
sehr eingeschränkt noch einen
bündnispartner im traditionellen sinne
ist so wie es das früher war amerikaner
verfolgen egoistisch ihre eigenen
interessen ohne rücksicht auf verluste
egal wo auf der welt eine deutsche eine
europäische politik die souveränen wäre
wäre gut beraten sich zu distanzieren
von dieser politik sich in einer welt
die sich neu sortiert mit neuen
machtzentren zu denen auch russland und
china gehört so aufzustellen dass man zu
allen beteiligten seiten zu den
amerikanern wie auch zu den russen und
den chinesen gute verhältnisse gute
beziehung unterhält und sich nicht
einseitig in richtung drängen lässt wir
tun uns keinen gefallen damit als
juniorpartner der amerikaner in
vorauseilendem gehorsam gegebenenfalls
uns auch an kriegerischen handlungen zu
beteiligen die nicht im europäischen
sinne sind 2003 hat sich die damalige
bundesregierung aus guten grund dem
völkerrechtswidrigen angriff auf den
irak verweigert ebenso wie die
französische wenn es heute zu einem
krieg kommen sollte gegen den iran
dann werden die usa mit an sicherheit
grenzender wahrscheinlichkeit diesen
ihren angriff auf den iran
beziehungsweise die iranischen
verteidigungsmaßnahmen in anschluss zum
nato verteidigungsfall erklären und dann
möchte ich mal sehen wie die
bundesregierung in berlin darauf
reagiert russland und china werden sich
hinter den iran stellen und das kann
sehr schnell sehr gefährlich sein und
ich glaube dass viele völlig
unterschätzen welche gefahr davon
ausgeht grundsätzlich glaube ich wenn
man die länder des nahen und mittleren
ostens betrachtet gibt es und das gilt
nicht nur für dortige region zwei
möglichkeiten oder zwei optionen
man kann in die wirklichkeit
hineinprojizieren auf der grundlage
bestehender ideologischer oder
überzeugungen oder man kann in der
wirklichkeit lesen und zur kenntnis
nehmen was dort passiert und wenn man
letzteres tut dann weiß man dass man die
welt nicht und gut und böse einteilen
sollte es gibt nicht nur die guten die
bösen es gibt viele grautöne
es führt jetzt soweit zum thema jammern
können uns jetzt noch mehr ordnen aber
es ist wichtig doch noch mal klar und
deutlich zu sagen dass ihre darstellung
des sieges im kämen also wirklich mit
der realität und mit einer nüchternen
bestandsaufnahme vor ort nichts zu tun
hat
die anderen letzte frage würden sie
sagen wenn sie jetzt diesen konflikt mit
dem iran und im nahen osten europas pro
toto sozusagen es für die welt nehmen
ist der multilateralismus mit einer
starken un ist dass am ende wenn das
abkommen wirklich scheitert in der tat
setzt der amerikanische präsident auf
die bilaterale sungun ist amerika immer
der stärkere politisch wirtschaftlich
militärisch er findet in der
europäischen union in der handelspolitik
einen ebenbürtigen counterpart deswegen
hatte auch bisher davor zurückgeschreckt
entsprechend wirtschafts aktionen gegen
die deutsche automobilindustrie zu
verhängen wir hoffen dass wir das
verhindern können weil wir da in dieser
frage geschlossen stehen und wenn wir in
außen- und sicherheitspolitischen fragen
genauso geschlossen agieren würden als
europäische union wie wir das zum
beispiel in der handelspolitik
gottseidank tun
dann wäre das schon besser für uns und
für die welt aber ich möchte trotzdem
einsatz noch sagen der rückreise der
amerikanische präsident hat heute mehr
amerikanische soldaten auf europäischen
boden der nato als sein vorgänger das
getan hatte
und ich glaube dass wir uns im blick auf
die verteidigung unserer freiheit hier
in europa auch weiterhin auf amerika
verlassen
ich bedanke mich sehr herzlich für die
durchaus kontroverse diskussion hier am
tisch und ich bedanke mich bei ihnen
sehr herzlich fürs zuschauen morgen
sehen sie hier zu dieser zeit die
phoenix runde und jetzt folgte michael
kolz mit der tag auch er kümmert sich um
das thema iran
aber es gibt auch innenpolitische themen
wie zb der fall
[Musik]
der 10
[Applaus]